[موسيقى] على بعد
سبعة أميال من الساحل الغربي لإستونيا في
أوروبا الشرقية ، تقع جزيرة الزورق الصغيرة ،
وهي مكان رعوي وهادئ
يشعر بالضياع في الوقت المناسب موطنًا لـ 400 شخص فقط ،
وهو يعمل كواحد من
المجتمعات الأمومية القليلة في العالم ،
وهو مكان تتدحرج فيه النساء
حسنًا ، في الغالب كل شيء اسمي
موراليس أتركه تقريبًا كل حياتي في هذه
الجزيرة نمط حياتنا مختلف
مقارنة نمط الحياة في البر الرئيسي
العديد من الإضافات القديمة إلى حياتنا أحد هذه
التقاليد هو أن رجال الزوارق يقضون
شهورًا في الصيد البحري
للجزيرة وفي الوقت نفسه الزوارق  النساء
مسؤولات عن قيادة المجتمع
والحفاظ على أسلوبه في الحياة ،
كان الرجال دائمًا وقتًا خاطئًا بعيدًا عن
تايلاند ، وبعض الأسباب التاريخية التي
تجعل المرأة تصبح طفلًا قويًا
ومستقلًا للغاية لا توجد أسئلة
مثيرة للاهتمام لأننا قتلنا
أزياء التناوب لأنني كل يوم
ترتدي أنها تصنع التنانير لأن
لديها أربع حفيدات لدينا
أغاني فولكلورية قديمة لا تزال حية ورقصات
لديهم  الكثير من المهارات العملية حول كيفية
العيش طوال العام هنا ، نعم ، الحياة
هنا أكثر صعوبة للبقاء على قيد الحياة ، إنها
كنز لسكان
الجزيرة الذين وصفوا جميعًا الجزيرة بأنها مثل
الجنة ، إنها أفضل مكان في العالم
لم يصنعوا فيه عصر الكاميرا الصخرية
صورة في وجهها لتكوين مفتاح الحلقة
كما لو مشيت مرة أخرى لطيفة والموظف
يقول ki tamanna machine بالقرب من قوانين
العدالة الخاصة بنا ، وأسرع بدء التجارة في زقاق
الملابس ، والموسيقى ،
والرقص الذي تم الاعتراف به من قبل اليونسكو
على تراثها الثقافي غير المادي
ضع قائمة بأغاني الزفاف الرئيسية والعديد من
التقاليد التي يزيد
عمرها عن ألفي عام ، لذا فإن هذا هو الشيء الرئيسي الذي
يجعلنا مدرجين في قائمة اليونسكو هذه.
تختفي ، إنها
ذات قيمة كبيرة إذا كانت هذه الأشياء لا تزال موجودة
ووصلت والعالم الحديث
معجزة حقًا
[موسيقى]